Tụi thế, hai giờ chương mùi thần sau, thì sinh có mắt tại phòng thi để làm thuộc tụi thị và ngay phổ biển mỗi quy, quy trẻ thi và lịch thi.
Khi thi chính thức diện ra trong hàng ngày mởi một đỏ mi hai thần sau, tụi thế ngày mởi một thần sau, thì sinh sức thi hai mỗi nước văn và tỏng.
Ngài mi hai thần sau, thì sinh làm bài thi hai mỗi tụi trọng đã đăng kỹ.
Đây là kỳ thi ghí nhận quy mỗi lượng khi có hơn một phởi hai mai chụi thi sinh.
Tăng hơn sau mỗi mỗi nghĩ sau trong em, sau bên năm hàng y tụi trọng hàng lâm.
Đây cũng là năm đầu tiên kỳ thi được chân khai tại 3 mươi tình thành phố sau khi thực hiện sắp sếp đơn vị hành trình.
Khi đồng hàng nghìn bốn trăm tà mấy mấy đỉnh thi và gần 5 mi nhìn phòng thi trên trọng quốc.
Về quy trẻ tuần sinh, thi sinh cần tập biệt lưu ý quy định, nên tham gia sếp tuần đại học mằng mất kỳ phương tức nào.
Tụi điểm, tổ hợp 8 muôn sếp tuần của thi sinh mất vộp và đặt tương mở lắm điểm thi tốt như phỏng phổ thông.
Trời lên!